so yeah the last 48 hours or so I've
been quite ridiculous I have final exam
yesterday my alarm this morning was set
for 4 o'clock a.m. so that gives you an
idea of how crunch the schedule has been
but we're on our way to dead Mouse's
house to fly some drums so it's worth it
yeah you know what it's a lot more
accessible and less restrictive than say
an RC car RC car you know you can have
to go and find a parking lot or you know
I have a really big driveway or you know
what I mean even that gets boring after
a while but with aerospace even if it's
limited to 50 feet it's like air is
everywhere you know you can fly it
around around so there's no as far as
like you can see there we're going
further these will go a miles in any
direction horizontally and then about
700 feet up but you can really see you
just and just go yeah it's kind of like
an RC car I've never flown anything at
all before today but I'd been like a
huge fan of RC cars and just racing
little cars around and basically like
the fact that the other so user-friendly
helps a lot where you add that axis but
it's not a big distraction because you
still have full control it still breaks
for you it still stops when you let go
so it's very similar if it's maintaining
your altitude you're kind of just
thinking about it like you would an RC
it totally makes sense too because you
mentioned you're like oh it's easy cuz
the you know the controller great yeah
they're set of left and right versus the
up and down yeah that helps a lot are
you kidding I'm joking can I keep up yes
I can keep
this is the beater this is one of us was
like I just slides this together last
night so that's what this is for wow
that really helps and this doesn't come
with it does it because I must have
threw that that's better
I can't wait to try and shoot that thing
down
it's pretty easy right yeah separating
Maxine is helpful you want to turn its
left and right on the up and down but we
will shift your orientation okay god I
find it super useful just to try and you
know always keep it like lined up so
like my straight yeah it's actually a
lot easier than I thought I'd be I guess
taking off and landing is the hardest it
makes you feel like a kid again
yeah I was gonna say like growing up we
went through a bunch of RC cars you use
it for like you know few weeks few
months and then it's like the battery
divers whatever but this is like
completed for ball game because flies
like even past cars because I was into
like RC cars and stuff but then you get
like these things that can go on
different surfaces and like climb over
stuff so you're just exploring basically
and just messing around see what you can
do with it so having that third
dimension to just literally explore see
what you can do with it yeah I think
that's the agent people like that a lot
power fly
so shoot all right right there
so much less of a pain in the ass to
land so we got the drums and we also
know dead Mouse's are pretty sweet and
clarin so let's combine the two
if you keep referencing finals that this
is so much better than taking fine
oh dude we lost them we kept them for
like 50 years
ultimate reg is going to be the oculus
with the head tracking and when you move
your head
there's no second pile you're piloting
when you move your head it moves the
camera yeah that's the ultimate like
when you're moving control around I'm
looking at the the iPad which is showing
you what the cameras seeing it was
really really close to real-time and it
was a high frame rate so it was like I
could watch smelt thank for Digg yeah so
put in Langer face honestly if you told
me you're in the plane with drones all
day today I might not have been as
excited I might not have been as into it
but now after having flown them I used
to be into RC cars I've said that before
and I'm like still really pumped about
that kind of stuff it was so much fun
moving from a small drone to the larger
drone to the inspire was also a lot of
fun
clearly attaching a camera to a flying
machine you unlock a whole world of
possibilities of new shots and I was a
video week that's pretty sweet and
hanging out with deadmau5 didn't hurt
that either
you